[Music]
[Music]
the kind of neuroscience that I do my
colleagues do it's almost like the
weatherman
we are always chasing storms we want to
see in measure storms bring storms that
is and we all talk about bring storms in
our daily lives
but we rarely see or listen to one so I
always like to start this starts by
actually introducing you to one of them
actually the first time we recorded more
than one neuron a hundred brain cells
simultaneously we could measure the
electrical sparks of a hundred cells in
the same animal this is the first image
we got the first 10 seconds of these
recordings we got a little snippet of a
thought and we could see an in front of
us I always tell the students that we
could also call neuroscientists some
sort of astronomer because we are
dealing with a system that is only
comparable in terms of number cells to
the number of galaxies that we have in
the universe and here we are out of
billions of neurons just recording 10
years ago a hundred we are doing a
thousand now and we hope to understand
something fundamental about our human
nature because if you don't know yet
everything that we use to define what
human nature is comes from these storms
come from the storms they roll over the
hills and valleys of our brains and
define our memories our beliefs our
feelings our plans for the future
everything that we ever do everything
that every human has ever done do a will
do require the toil of populations of
narrows producing this kind of storms
and the sound of a brain storm if you
never heard one it's someone like this
if allowed there if you could my son
calls this making popcorn while
listening to a badly tuned a.m. station
this is a brain this is what happens
when you route these electrical storms
to a loudspeaker and you listen to a 100
brain cells fine
your brain will listen or you'll sound
like this my brain any brain and what we
want to do as neuroscientists in in this
time is to actually listen to this
synchronous this brings synchronous and
try to extract from them the messages
they carry in particularly about 12
years ago we create a preparation that
we named brain machine interfaces and
you have a skin here that describes how
it works the idea is let's have some
sensors that listen to these storms this
electrical fine and see if we can in the
same time that it takes for this storm
to leave the brain and reach the legs of
their arms of an animal they have about
half a second let's see if we can read
these signals extract the motor messages
that is embedded in it translating to
digital commands and central artificial
device that will reproduce the voluntary
motor we love that brain in real-time
and see if we can measure how well we
can translate that message when we
compare to the way the body does that
and if we can actually provide feedback
saying sensory signals that go back from
this robotic mechanical computational
actuator that is now under to control
the brain back to the brain how the
brain deals with that of receiving
messages from an artificial piece of
machinery and this is exactly what we
did ten years ago we started with a
superstar monkey call aurora that became
one of the superstars of this field and
i rather like to play video games as you
can see here she likes to use a joystick
like any one of us any of our kids to
play this game and as a good primate she
even tries to cheat before she gets the
right answer so even before a target
appears that she's supposed to cross so
the cursor that she's controlling with
this joystick Aurora is trying to find
the target no matter
where it is and if she's doing that
because every time she crossed that
target with the little cursor she gets a
drop of Brazilian orange juice and I can
tell you any monkey will do anything for
you if you get that little drop of
Brazilian oranges actually any primate
will do that think about that well while
Radha was playing this game as you saw
in doing you know a thousand trials a
day and getting ninety seven percent
correct and 350 ml of orange juice we
are recording the brain storms that are
producing her head and sending to a
robotic arm that was learning to
reproduce the movements that our I was
making because the idea was to actually
turn on this brain machine interface in
heaven rora
played the game just by thinking without
the interference or her body her brain
storms would control her arm that will
move the cursor and cross the target
into our shock that's exactly what her
aura did she played the game without
moving her body so every trajectory that
we see the cursor now this is the exact
first moment she got that that's the
exact first moment a brain intention was
liberated from the physical domains of a
body of a primate and could act outside
in that outside world just by
controlling an artificial device an
Aurora kept playing the game kept
finding their little target and getting
the orange juice that she wanted to get
that she craved for well she did that
because she at that time had acquired
and you armed the robotic arm that you
see moving here thirty days later after
the first video that I showed you is the
under the control of Aurora's brain and
is moving the cursor to get to the
target in Aurora now knows that she can
play the game of this robotic arm but
she has not lost the ability to use her
biological arms to do what she pleases
she can scratch her back she can scratch
one of us she can play another game by
all purposes and means Aurora's brain
has incorporated that artificial device
as an extension of her body the model of
the cell
that Aurora had in her mind has been
expanded to get one more arm well we did
that 10 years ago just fit forward 10
years just last year we realized that
you don't need even to have a robotic
device you can just build a
computational body an avatar a monkey
avatar and you can actually use it for
our monkeys to either interact to them
or you can train them to assume in a
virtual world the first person's
perspective of that avatar and use her
brain activity to control the movements
of the avatar arms or legs and what we
did basically was to train the animals
to learn how to control these avatars in
explore objects that appear in a virtual
world and these objects are visually
identical but when the Avatar crosses
the surface of these objects there is an
electrical message message that is
proportional to the micro tactile
texture of the object that goes back
directly to the monkey's brain informing
the brain what is that the avatar is
touching and in just four weeks the
brain learns to process this new
sensation and acquires a new sensory
pathway like a new sense and you truly
liberate the brain now because you are
allowing the brain to send motor
commands to move this avatar and the
feedback that comes from the Avatar is
being processed directly by the brain
without the interference of the skin so
what you see here is this is the design
of the task on you're going to see an
animal basically touching these three
targets and it has to select one because
only one carries the reward they aren't
juice that they want to get and it has
to select it by touch using a virtual
arm arm that doesn't exist and that's
exactly what they do this is a complete
liberation of the brain from the
physical constraints of the body in the
motor
in a perceptual task the enemy's
controlling the Avatar to touch the
targets and is sensing the texture by
receiving an electrical message directly
in the brain and the brain is deciding
what is the texture associated to the
reward with the legends that you see in
the movie doesn't appear for the monkey
and by the way they don't read English
anyway so they are here just for you to
know that the correct target is shifting
position and yet they can find them by
tactile discrimination and they can
press it and select it so when we look
at the brains of these animals on the
top panel you see the alignment of 125
cells showing what happens with the
brain activity the electrical storms of
this sample of neurons in the brain when
the enemy is using a joystick and that's
a picture that a veneer of physiology
knows the basically alignment shows that
these cells are coding for all possible
directions the bottom picture is what
happens when the body stops moving in
the enemy starts controlling either a
robotic device or a computational avatar
as fast as we can reset our computers
the brain activity shifts to start
representing this new - as if this -
wasn't an a part of that primates body
the brain is simulating that - as fast
as we can measure so that suggests to us
that our sense of self does not end at
the last layer of the epithelium of our
bodies but he ends at the last layer of
electrons of the two that were
commanding with our brains our violence
our cars our a bicycles or soccer balls
our clothing they all become assimilated
by this voracious amazing dynamic system
called the brain how far can we take it
well an experiment that we run a few
years ago we took this to the limit we
had an animal running a treadmill at
Duke University in the East Coast of the
United States and producing the brain
storms necessary to move and we had a
robotic device humanoid robot in Kyoto
Japan an ATR
laboratories there was dreaming its
entire life to be controlled by a brain
a human brain or a primate brain what
happens here is that the brain activity
that generated the movements in the
monkey was transmitted to Japan and made
this robot walk while footage of this
walking was sent back to Duke so that a
monkey could see the legs of this robot
walking in front of her so she could be
rewarded not by what her body was doing
but for every correct step of the robot
on the other side of the planet
controlled by her brain activity funny
thing that round trip around the globe
took 20 milliseconds less than it takes
for that brainstorm to leave its head
the head of the monkey in reach its own
muscle the monkey was moving a robot
that was six times bigger across the
planet is this one of the experiments in
which that robot was able to walk
autonomously is this cb1 fulfilling its
dream in Japan under the control brain
activity of a primate so while we're
taking all this what we are going to do
with all this research besides studying
the properties of this dynamic universe
that we have between our ears well the
idea is to take all this knowledge and
technology and try to restore one of the
most severe neurological problems that
we have in the world millions of people
have lost the ability to translate these
brainstorms into action into movement
although their brains continue to
produce those storms encode for
movements they cannot cross a barrier
that was created by a lesion on the
spinal cord so our idea is to create a
bypass it's to use this brain machine
interfaces to read these signals
largest-scale brain storms that contain
the desire to move again bypass the
lesion using computational and Micro
engineering and send it to a new body a
whole body call an axis
a whole robotic suit that will become
the new body of these patients and you
can see an image produced by this
consortium this is a non profit from
source and called a walk again project
that is putting together scientists from
Europe from here the United States and
in Brazil together to work to actually
get this new body built a body that we
believe through the same plastic
mechanisms that allow our Rohr and other
monkey's to use these tools through a
brain machine interface and that allows
us to incorporate the tools that we
produce and use in our daily life the
same mechanism we hope allow these
patients not only to imagine again the
movements that they want to make and
translate them into movements of this
new body but for this body to be
assimilated as the new body that the
brain controls so I was told about 10
years ago that this would never happen
that this was close to impossible and I
can only tell you that as a scientist I
grew up in southern Brazil in the
mid-60s watching a few crazy guys
telling that they would go to the moon
and I was five years old and I never
understood why NASA didn't hire Captain
Kirk and Spock to do the job after all
they were very proficient but just
seeing that as a kid made me believed as
my grandmother used to tell me that
impossible is just possible that someone
has not put enough effort to make it
come true so they told me that is
impossible to make someone walk I think
I'm going to follow my grandmother's
advice thank you
[Applause]
[Music]